das war wohl eher eine ausraster zu viel
ernst august von hannover sitzt im knast
der 66-jährige soll ein ehepaar bedroht
und randaliert haben
es ist der neueste ausraster in einer
ganzen reihe von fehltritten bedrohungen
und pöbel angriffen
die polizei umstellte jetzt sein
jagdhaus rückte sogar mit body camps
gegen den prinzen aus und bei mir im
studio ist jetzt désirée nick denn sie
kennen die familie sehr gut waren 17
jahre lang mit dem bruder von ernst
august haben gemeinsam einen sohn kennen
als auch ernst august mehr als gut sagen
sie uns als sie das jetzt gehört haben
waren sie überrascht also ich glaube
dass ich die spitze des eisberges und es
ist ja so bevor etwas sichtbar wird muss
es ja nachweislich sein
ich bin überrascht dass diese ausfälle
erst jetzt stattfinden weil diese
familie oftmals in den medien völlig
falsch eingeschätzt wurde
das sind sehr toxische
familienstrukturen die sich einem
außenstehenden völlig verschließen
beispielsweise lese ich immer in den
medien ja ernst august von hannover war
ja nicht bei der hochzeit seines sohnes
mit der russischen ehefrau dr geheiratet
hatte katharina marie schäfer und es war
aber auch schon der vater von zehn jahre
ernst august nicht bei der hochzeit
seines sohnes also mit chantal hochuli
die erste frau von ernst august das
heißt diese strukturen nicht zu den
hochzeiten der kinder zu gehen sich
nicht um seine kinder zu kümmern
seine kinder nicht zu kennen das ist in
dieser familie der die gangart das ist
deren normalität zum beispiel kennt ja
die tochter von caroline von monaco also
alexandra da ist ja der vater an frau
kennt ihren vater ja auch nicht der
vater meines kindes theilig von hannover
hat unseren gemeinsamen sohn auch um
sein umgangsrecht betrogen was ein
moralisches verbrechen ist dass es aber
die struktur sie müssen zur kenntnis
nehmen dass die einzige tochter des
letzten deutschen kaisers
prinzessin victoria luise das war ja
eine hannover prinzessin die wurde von
ihren eigenen söhnen aus den latifundien
der welfen heraus geklagt von der
marienburg von haus gutenberg sie ist
dann eingezogen bei wohlhabenden
anständigen menschen in braunschweig die
sie aufgenommen haben und dafür haben
die da eine kommode bekommen das ist ein
völlig anderer verhaltenskodex man löst
probleme nicht durch gespräch man hört
nicht zu er hasst die gegenseitige
verachtung die missachtung in dieser
familie ist der stoff aus dem die gewebt
sind und deshalb behaupte ich ja da ich
diese familienstrukturen so gut kenne
ich wäre für ernst august die richtige
gesprächspartnerin
denn ich kenne das klima ich kenne die
regeln sie müssen sich vorstellen dass
der vater von diesen söhnen heinrich und
ernst-august den kindern beigebracht hat
ihr seid nicht von gottes gnaden das war
schon ein fortschritt dass er so modern
ist dass er seinen kindern vermittelt
ihr seid menschen
der vater noch dachte er wäre von gottes
gnaden diese familie steht in ihrem
selbstverständnis über dem gesetz hinzu
kommt dass ernst august natürlich nur
umgeben ist von menschen die das
bedienen weil alle andere fliegen ja
schon im vorfeld aus oder durch sieg und
so ergibt sich da ein sehr fragiles
gefüge wo es mich überrascht dass es so
lange gut gehen konnte
jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt sie werden
die richtige gesprächspartnerin für ihn
wie würden sie ihn denn jetzt helfen in
dieser situation wenn die familie wie
sie es gerade mal gesagt habe nie mehr
nicht helfen wird in dieser familie
hilft man sich nicht ernst august hat
eines der größten netzwerke die man
haben kann eine große familie in monaco
viele geschwistern er hat diverse
schwestern und er ist natürlich als teil
des deutschen hochadels umgeben von
einer gigantischen courage
man guckt sich nicht an man hilft sich
wie sind sie denn helfen sich ja durch
gespräche happy ich möchte noch mal
ich habe jahrelang in der
jugendstrafanstalt plötzensee als jugend
seelsorgerin gearbeitet ich habe kaffee
getrunken mit 14 jährigen die die oma
erschlagen haben wegen 30 euro liefern
mich alle ganz toll also es ihm mit mit
solchen opfern verstümmelten den
defizitären wesen umzugehen das ist mir
sehr nah man mag das auch in dem podcast
ja ja sehr erfolgreich ist den ich seit
august mosel oder bei invitation only
invitation only würde ernst august sehr
gefallen
lose luther würde er in mir sehen also
auch da eine kleine verrückung es ist
alles verrückt bei denen wie man ja sagt
in der psychologie es ist verrückt ein
anderer aspekt aber er würde mich als
gesprächspartnerin sehr schätzen weil
wir nicht bei null anfangen weil ich ja
weiß mit welcher missachtung und mit
welchem aus welchem blickwinkel die auf
ganz leben schauen und das sind eben
keine bürgerlichen perspektive